Ya.
Jadi ke depannya ada bit
dan qubit yang akan jadi fondasi komputasi masa depan
yang bisa kita pakai untuk mengatasi
masalah-masalah kompleks di dunia ini
jadi yuk kita coba pahami perbedaan di antara keduanya
dan di mana kekuatan qubit itu berasal
kalau kita lihat di sisi kiri
ini adalah cara untuk menggambarkannya dan kita akan pakai diagram-diagram ini
sepanjang presentasi ini untuk
menunjukkan kekuatannya — kita lihat ada lingkaran
dan dua titik, saat titiknya ada di kutub utara
itu adalah nol, dan saat di kutub selatan itu adalah satu
itulah dua keadaan bit klasik. Nah, qubit adalah
satuan informasi dalam dunia kuantum
dan di sini kita punya gambarnya
seperti bola, ada nol dan satu
dan kita bisa punya keduanya dalam keadaan superposisi ini
kita punya trik istimewa yang tersedia buat kita
bukan cuma kita bisa menempatkannya di mana saja dalam bola ini
tapi bayangkan setiap salah satu dari ini
itu seperti bulan kecil
yang ada di dalam bola itu dan kita bisa memutar bulannya
jadi di sini kamu lihat bahwa
bola di bawah sudah diputar sedikit
makanya kamu lihat sedikit warna biru
dan merah muda dan kita bisa memutar sampai penuh
nah ini adalah pergeseran seratus delapan puluh derajat
jadi kita punya konsep fase yang diberikan oleh kuantum ini
tiga kekuatan super yang dimiliki oleh qubit
yaitu kekuatan superposisi
kekuatan interferensi
dan kekuatan entanglement
jadi yuk kita bahas — prinsip superposisi sebenarnya
cukup mudah untuk dipahami
jadi yang di sisi kiri
kita punya kutub utara nol atau kutub selatan satu
dan kalau kita gabungkan dua keadaan itu
sekarang kita punya qubit superposisi yang punya keduanya
nol dan satu secara bersamaan, di utara
dan selatan. Diagram kanan itu sama
tapi sekarang kita mau pakai sedikit trik
kita akan terapkan sebuah gate, sebuah quantum gate
pada apa yang kita lakukan di sini, ingat
kita bisa mengubahnya sekarang, kita bisa
memutar bulan-bulan kecil ini kan
jadi kita sudah memutarnya seratus
delapan puluh derajat dan sekarang kita punya satu
jadi sekarang saat kita menjumlahkan nol plus satu, kita hasilkan
sebuah keadaan superposisi
tapi perhatikan, ini berbeda
dan yang di kiri, kita
masih nol dan satu tapi sekarang dengan keadaan yang sudah diputar
untuk yang satu itu. Nah itu akan sangat powerful
untuk memanfaatkan hal kedua yang benar-benar menarik, yaitu
prinsip interferensi
dan ini bukan operasi yang bisa kita lakukan dalam komputasi klasik
jadi di sini dalam contoh ini kita punya
nol dan satu di kiri, ditambah
keadaan baru yang kita buat tadi
yang juga nol dan satu
tapi dengan bulan yang sudah diputar itu. Saat kita lakukan ini
kita bisa menginterferensikan dua keadaan itu
dan perhatikan ada hal yang sungguh menarik terjadi
kita sudah menghilangkan keadaan satu
dan kita berakhir dengan keadaan nol saja
kita berhasil melakukan itu karena kita menginterferensikan keadaan-keadaan itu
jadi peluang berikutnya yang kita miliki sekarang
adalah berapa banyak keadaan yang bisa kita buat
dan hal indahnya dalam kuantum adalah kita bisa membuat jumlah yang eksponensial
dari keadaan-keadaan itu. Jadi yuk kita lihat sistem yang punya
lima qubit. Dalam kasus ini kita menggambarkan qubit-qubit ini
sebagai qubit-qubit yang independen ya, kamu lihat mereka di kiri
nol-nol dan satu-satu, dan mereka dikalikan. Kita punya lima
dari mereka, jadi jumlah keadaan yang bisa kita buat di
komputer kuantum yang digambarkan sebagai bola di sebelah kanan
adalah dua pangkat
jumlah qubit yang kita punya, dalam kasus ini lima
jadi dua pangkat lima adalah tiga puluh dua keadaan
jadi kita lihat tiga puluh dua bulan kecil itu
perhatikan bahwa dalam kasus ini kita tidak memasukkan
fase apa pun, semuanya merah muda. Aspek powerful dari
penggunaan properti ini yang disebut entanglement dalam dunia kuantum
adalah kita bisa membuat keadaan-keadaan baru
seperti yang digambarkan di sebelah kanan
di mana kita punya kombinasi antara merah muda
dan biru, di mana keadaan itu tidak bisa digambarkan
sebagai perkalian independen dari
lima qubit ini
karena kita punya tiga puluh dua keadaan
apa yang ini beritahu kita sebenarnya adalah sesuatu yang sangat mendalam